manly adrenaline-fueled testosterone
manliness that should be the tagline of
his movie Fast & Furious 6 can you
believe that I'm even saying that I mean
for goodness sakes there are six movies
in this franchise and there's gonna be a
seven that is absurd
what's even more absurd is that they're
not crap they actually got better I
didn't really like any of the Fast &
Furious movies all that much I thought
they were disposable okay fun until Fast
Five which was really fun and a really
well directed action movie like it
actually had very well directed action
scenes a lot of really good humor and it
decided to sidestep the whole let's make
it all about street racing every single
one of them street racing street racing
and they made it about this bank heist
it was actually really interesting and
fun and the director of that film Justin
Lane is returning
thank goodness for Fast and Furious 6
this film stars the entire crew from the
previous film plus Gina Carano and
Michelle Rodriquez reprising her former
role in the film in this film if you've
seen the trailers basically Vin Diesel
is brought back into the action because
his former girlfriend is apparently
alive who he thought was dead also
there's this crazy villain played by
Luke Evans who's out to find this
extremely important computer chip I
guess and Dwayne Johnson and Gina Carano
our partners on the police force and
they enlist the help of Vin Diesel and
his crew to bring this guy down Fast &
Furious 6 is a lot of fun it knows
exactly what it is and it's not trying
to be anything else
this is over-the-top in-your-face
adrenaline fuelled testosterone man fest
filled with car chases fistfights
running chases explosions planes and of
course bikini clad booties it would be a
huge mistake for me and I think any film
critic to try to judge this film beyond
what it's trying to be this film is
trying to be nothing more than an
awesome action movie and a great
injection of summer fun something that I
think we have been sorely lacking so far
this year this movie brings it it has
nothing but fast-paced action sequences
and a lot of really good humor that
actually had me laughing I'm kind of a
hard laugh when it comes to movies it's
a little bit hard to get a laugh out of
me I can sometimes chuckle or smile at
something but this movie had me falling
a lot yes I just said guffaw because I'm
apparently 56 years old if you go
in this movie expecting anything other
than a fast in the Furious movie and a
really good one you're going to be
disappointed let's talk a little bit
about the plot of this movie car chases
man car chases there's a chip an evil
computer chip and there's a bad guy Luke
Evans who's after it and I got to stop
it and Michelle Rodriquez ain't dead
that's the plot let's do some car chases
this movie is directed very very well
Justin Lin understands how to direct an
action sequence there is no stupid
unnecessary shaky-cam and quick cuts
every split second this movie has a lot
of wide takes and angles of real stunt
work done by real vehicles done by real
stuntmen and it is enthralling I was
extremely excited whenever an action
sequence started in this movie because
they were directed so well and they were
so so much fun to watch I won't spoil
anything for you but be sure to not get
up as soon as the credits start there's
a little something extra for you to
enjoy acting in the movie serviceable
just fine honestly I mean it's they know
what they're doing they've been doing it
a lot this is the sixth one they
shouldn't hope hi now how to make these
movies and it's about in my opinion on
par with a fifth one there are certain
elements about it that are better than
the fifth one for instance the villain
in this movie played by Luke Evans is
much better than the villain in the
fifth one the villain the fifth one was
just you know he was okay he did the job
whatever the villain in this movie
actually got his hands dirty he went out
and he did stuff he drove around the
cars Luke Evans did a pretty good job in
this movie he was a fun menacing villain
you know they have their scenes where
they stand there and they talk and
they're like you're a bad guy and I'm a
good guy I'm gonna tell you what's right
and wrong and you're gonna listen
because I'm the good guy but I'm bad guy
and I'm gonna tell you that you're gonna
die your family's gonna die but I'm the
good guy my name is Vin Diesel and I'm
gonna kill you because I'm Vin Diesel
that's the movie basically I just really
think it'd be a really big mistake if
you go into this movie expecting
anything else and what it is there's
fast cars those booties there's lots of
fistfights in action and it's all done
very well all the people in this movie
have worked together for so long and the
biggest theme of The Fast and the
Furious movie seems to be family and
togetherness and you take care of those
that you love and you really feel that
in this movie these actors have good
chemistry they really do
and they work well together one thing I
really like is the fast and furious
movies are just filled with different
ethnicities there's so many different
people black white asian whatever if
there is one thing you could ever say
derogatorily about these movies it's not
that they're whitewashed or their race
specific or something there's everything
in this movie the action sequences are
going to blow you out of the water if
you want to critique the acting of the
film go ahead I mean it doesn't really
matter they all do what they have to do
they're serviceable performances and
Dwayne Johnson is also awesome it's
going to say that guy is awesome in
everything nowadays I'm really loving
that guy he's kind of becoming one of
the best action heroes of our day Vin
Diesel's phoning the movie paul walker
spot-on the movie all the actors have a
good time Tyrese Gibson and Ludacris and
the way they go back and forth of one
another good chemistry good humor
legitimately good humor Fast & Furious 6
is a great summer movie it's a lot of
fun it's a cheesy movie with with like
stunt work that would like never happen
with stunts they're like yeah okay no
it's just not in real life buddy but
need I remind you this is fast in the
Furious 6 I'm gonna get fast in the
Furious 6 and a - that's right because
I'll tell you why this movie does what
it wants to do extremely well it's a
very technically well-constructed movie
and in my opinion you can't blame this
movie for having such a small little
plot and silly over-the-top action it's
fast in the Furious 6 how many times
have to say it a - it's a good frickin
movie go check it out it's a lot of fun
have fun with it the action scenes are
well directed and I enjoyed it thanks
for watching guys and as always if you
liked this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes
[Music]